one of the saddest displays that we've
seen in a long time
madonna shows up
in a sort of leather skimpy outfit she's
like a dominatrix you know 50 shades of
grey kind of thing
and
she is standing there i guess is a sex
symbol she used to be a sex symbol this
woman is 63 years old i don't mean to be
insulting she looks pretty good for 63 i
guess
but she's 63. she shouldn't be wearing
this it's gross don't do it
and this is what our society is now
exalting as the height of freedom
the freedom of a 63 year old woman
to dress up like a
like a woman of ill repute
alone
on stage
putatively for the sexual gratification
of the audience but i don't think that
was actually the effect that's the
height of freedom right
no i don't think so this is i mentioned
george orwell earlier this is really
aldous huxley this is really brave new
world this is
the state coming in and undermining
people's freedom by appealing to their
most base desires which unfortunately is
a product not just of the radical left
but also of the libertarians
who
mistake
pursuing your appetites and your
whatever disorder desires you have for
true freedom and the result of that is
that people now become enslaved to their
sexual desires people become enslaved to
their drug desires people become
enslaved to all manner of selfishness
and they lose the ability to govern
themselves and this is
exploited by bad men who want to rule
over you regardless of your
constitutional order okay
really bad stuff and it's no coincidence
that this has happened with the decline
of religion john adams said the
constitution's built from moral and
religious people it is not fit to govern
anyone else
that wasn't just
a talking point that what he was
observing is that if you do not have
religion and morality to reign in your
basest appetites which are licentious
they're not they're not true liberty
then you're not gonna you're not gonna
be able to attain liberty you're not
gonna be able to govern yourself
so it's no coincidence that we have lost
our political rights as religion has
declined i'm so glad that you enjoyed
that clip i want you to enjoy the whole
show so head on over to
the michael knowles show at apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
head up before you go vote again in
california i assume you've already voted
once before someone voted for you
but before you go do it again subscribe
to the michael knowles show we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]